okay good afternoon everyone uh welcome
to the extraordinary
um
infrastructure Services committee
today 40 February we're here for to go
over the draft submission for the three
Waters bells two and three
um
right so we'll start there until 6.
thank you chair
counselors the paper before you today is
talking about a potential submission
that we would look to make to the three
Waters National transition units lead
draft legislation in Parliament at the
moment
um around next steps for
uh water reform it covers the water
services legislation bill and the water
services economic efficiency and
consumer protection Bill these are both
currently out for consultation and we
would propose that invercargill city
council make a submission with regard to
that that draft legislation
we currently have drafted a piece of
feedback to that and we put that in
front of council today the key pieces
that I would like to draw your attention
to are some of the concerns that we have
around
implications for invercargill city
council to have to continue to be
involved in on charging for the services
provided by the new three Waters
entities at the moment we could be
required to provide that service to the
new entities through to 2029
we have to enter into an agreement with
the new entities around the terms and
conditions that that would be on but
essentially if we can't come to an array
an agreement in that respect then an
agreement will essentially be determined
by the minister
ICC staff feels that this compels us to
essentially have to provide that that
charging and that's something that we
don't agree with these are no longer
assets that we are responsible for we
don't think we should be compelled to
continue to be involved in the charging
of those particularly given the uh
confusion that's likely to create with
customers around who is responsible for
those assets going forward
the other items that I'd like to draw
your attention to is the implication in
the draft legislation that the new
entity wouldn't pay rates for its pipe
Network in Council roads this would be
inconsistent with other utility
providers and inconsistent actually with
what happens for icc's Network at the
moment the three Waters team is actually
rated by the broader Council business in
that respect that's a key revenue for
Council going forward and if we didn't
have that Revenue would provide a
significant gap for us to fund in the
rates of space
we're also concerned about the process
for What's called the allocation
schedule which deals with which assets
are handed across and the debt that is
covered uh by The Entity back to
invercargill city council to take the
three Waters debt off our books
at the moment uh there will essentially
will receive an allocation of that debt
if we don't agree with it there appears
to be little right of reply for ICC and
again those determinations going through
going through the minister
we absolutely don't agree with that
position and there needs to be a right
of reply and negotiation in that respect
and the final one is around storm water
those who have been looking closely at
the three Waters reforms will understand
that it's been a controversial area as
to whether or not storm water goes
across as part of the three Waters
entities
uh the key issue there is at the moment
it is intending to transfer uh in part
but not in full it's a little bit
unclear by the draft legislation which
parts would stay with councils we don't
think it's sufficiently clear and
there's a little bit of a feeling that
the reticulated Network in urban areas
would go across and that there's a
number of pieces that are what we'd
almost call the wrap the rats and mice
pieces that are a little bit difficult
and intangible to get a hand on but take
up a significant amount of our time that
would stay with councils our concern is
that we wouldn't have the staff and the
expertise post-reform to be dealing with
that so we would like to see it being
clear one way or the other that storm
water if it's going goes across as a
whole responsibility area we accept that
transport related storm water curbs and
channels Etc would stay with us and that
private drainage as regulated under the
building code would stay with us but
beyond that we would like to see we're
suggesting that we'd like to see that go
across as a whole
those are the key points I wanted to
draw your attention to the submissions
are due in on the 17th this Friday this
will obviously have to go through
Council to be endorsed so we would
propose that we would provide the
submission on Friday noting that a final
endorsement would be required by council
at the next council meeting and then
we'd advise them once that was endorsed
thank you Erin uh so my apologies just
about housekeeping even though we've had
two meetings already I must do the
apologies for this meeting and so the
apology we have is councilor Campbell so
moved seconded thank you very much I'll
put that all those in favor
against that is carried right okay um
before I open the floor up I'll get
um Mia Clark just to say a couple of
words since he will be in in
recommendation three does or does not
wish to speak I hear that he does wish
to
speak
um to the Slick committee
um Bobby would you like to just open up
the discussions first yeah sure um so
two or three things uh the port report
it's excellent to Aaron and whoever else
probably Michael and others that had
some input into that
um I think there are still some wider
issues but I don't want to go back to
redraft given the time we've got
certainly some unease I think about how
they'll operate in the first 12 months
and where so many kpx funding or Capital
funding will come from and what the
risks of that are and certainly around
the issues that you talked about about
the geographical averaging how that
impacts with the council that already
has water meters and so there's a lot of
uncertainty around this proposal
um and we can't just sit here and think
that a national
coalition government will get rid of all
of it so we need to continue to lock
Lobby for the things that clearly out
right but the report covers most of what
I would suggest
um and certainly we should have a voice
at the table and certainly we should
stand alone on our submission not get
caught up in any joint submission
elsewhere I found it quite fast called
last time rang you know I went to the
select committee in Dunedin and spoke
that we had some colleagues from the
otago area
your target area who'd been adamant that
they were in favor of
um of this reform all the way through
we've got quite a flogging for being
outside their their support area
and I personally got some as well
um I need to find it when we got to the
select committee they were all opposed
to it because it was election time I
just thought that was quite classical
um so it's very much that we should
stand alone and make our own submission
and I'd be in favor of going to it if
it's in Dunedin that would be great but
if not then we go where we need to go
okay thanks for just to clear up
um the submission are we doing am I
doing a joint
so I've just had clarification from my
colleagues in central otago today who
were coordinating a joint submission
um their intention is not to do a joint
submission of councils their intention
is to do a submission on behalf of staff
at this point in time only to draw out
those five or six key issues that
everybody agrees on so that's something
that I'm happy to take some further
discussion on it would be nothing that
is in opposition to what we have put
forward just attempting to put further
strength to those five or six Keys yeah
and just in response to that chair um
look for those that attended the post
waitangi Day celebration that uh Claire
and I were both there getting a joint
submission up with the otago Southland
Network at the moment the zone six is
problematic
um it was very problematic on Dunedin
Hospital and has been on other issues as
well I think
we need to be absolutely sure that if
we're getting staff to give some input
to a submission what does that tell in
Pete that we've got a separate
submission from staff as opposed to
those that govern the councils
even if they're in agreeance
the I guess what I'd be saying is the
the reason it would be a separate staff
submission is simply that ability to try
to coordinate multiple councils all on
such a tight time play time time frame
is just logistically very difficult to
do it to achieve so bear with me again
as I just teased this out so
um I'd hate to think that that's getting
around the current discomfort we have in
our otago Southland Network at the mayor
removal
um and and that's driven in part because
we have quite unique needs what we need
another coil for three Waters is totally
different to Central tiger and other
areas so
um and over and above that we've got
Mito taking a position as well so I'm
not sure that we should be doing a staff
one as well
um it's a little bit like if I wanted to
get a position on what iot thought about
development in the city I'd approach the
chair of the board for that position I
wouldn't then go in and ask for some
feedback from the chief executive as
well sir I apologize I'd had some
different feedback when we held a
workshop on the matter around the desire
to put forward a joint submission so
that's what I've based going ahead on
um if it is a different decision of
council today then we can to amend that
I guess what I'm leading through chairs
for you is that while we might get all
our concerns bundled up with that we we
may be party to concerns that are not
ours
and that just widens the debate away
from where we've been I thought we were
neutral on That Joint Commission because
I was definitely against that for the
very reasons uh the mayor is mentioned
yeah
counselors and um Mr Mayor you may
recall that at the first round of
submissions there was a executive
director for
otago Southland Chief Executives on
three Waters and she presented a
submission
and her technical knowledge was valued
in the sense that she had previously
been the GM of infrastructure at Central
otago District
this legislation has a significant
impact on staff
and it has a significant impact on staff
who may transfer and it also has a
significant impact on staff who may not
transfer such as the customer services
staff where the legislation proposes
that we may well be continuing to front
that until July 2029. it's Julie's work
from the officials or the offices
perspective that is proposed unless it
is not in a political sense of the
um the impact of it which I would say I
completely understand is the purview of
council speaking the other half of their
communities this is from the purview of
Chief Executives talking about the
arrangements many of which quite frankly
have been delegated to officials in
government when one looks at the
legislation and I refer specifically to
the issue of agreeing the level of debt
that is delegated to the secretary for
the Department of internal affairs
rather than to the minister so these are
the sorts of details that I would
anticipate Julie would also be able to
answer if she was presenting to the
select committee
you happy with that don't we no not
really no um I I think that we're going
to make one submission on behalf of us
on behalf of this Council we should be
canvassing things that that clears just
right so we've got issues around with
all our water Engineers want to transfer
across the new organization and some may
not some may go to the private sector or
if we've got issues around
um I guess non-technical staffing issues
then we should signal that in our report
we should the council should I think
once you start having multiple reports
the the picture gets muddied and we saw
that recently with the Dunedin Hospital
situation it was an absolute mess
so is that at all possible
to do the uh starting
um I
I'm sorry counselors
um the timing of this is I think the
word I would use is fatiguing
uh and I don't wish to say it's
deliberate but by golly over the
Christmas period uh the mayor's positive
comments about the submission are very
valued in the sense that Aaron has done
95 of this work on her own at the last
minute
to now ask that further work be done
to include it
with your other priorities
is actually pushing staff Beyond
a reasonableness we just won't submit
just a final clarification on that chair
if you don't mind I wasn't suggesting we
changed this report at all what I'm
saying is if if the chief executive
group that want to Across The Tiger
Southland region put in the alternative
I think that's counter and secondly if
there are issues in there around
Staffing that we haven't got in our
report at this stage than they are not
significant in the overall scheme of
things
get this sorted and then we'll I'm going
to open the floor okay that's
right okay we'll leave that where it is
now I've got Ria first
um so I just wanted to um make a comment
from having set on sleep committees that
when we do have the chief executive come
through with a submission on behalf of
all Council it's usually collectively
done as that Council so that when you're
coming through your issues you outline
your most important issues to that
legislation
um but I have to say I've never seen
from and I understand what you're saying
Claire I've never seen a staff Network
submit
um in that same district or territory
Authority it would look like there is
not a one voice speaks for all and it
would devise a disservice if that
was the movement forward Mr chair I
would completely agree with the
counselor in this particular instance
the government is funding work being
done by regions by this executive
director there's actually a bit of
different play for this legislation than
there typically is for other policy
differences if I appreciate Council
since and we'll leave it at that
okay so really you're right yep no I
totally understand that and I do get
with the fatigueness but you know
legislation like this it is called for
that we do have to work that extra mile
to get but we want a head of the line
across the line so totally accept that
remark too okay Alex
um thank you Mr chair um just two points
on the matter
um one um in complete agreeance with
councilor Bond
um this isn't something that Council
does
um
non-frequently we've definitely had
submissions in the past where we put
forward a A View from our Council but we
also know that our team members have
been working in the background forming
their own submission that gives weight
regionally to uh whatever it is that
we're putting forward our for our for us
um my other point is that I believe our
officer was extremely clear that none of
what this the staff report would be put
forward as is in opposition to what we
have and I think that's really key
excuse me that
they're not going out and completely
changing their opinion or putting
forward things that we don't already
agree with we can trust in the fact that
our staff are putting forward a
submission on their own off their own
back but knowing that it's not in
opposition to what we've put forward
ourselves
um I'll just you know wait Nobby um
Leslie
questions in my opinion who better than
star to draw out the Staffing
implications at a select committee of
the particular issues that can't be
drawn out in such a
um Balsam way who better than a staff
submission to present the reality that
councils will not have the experts
remaining to have bits and pieces of of
the storm water left in council's hands
Etc who better than a staff person
presenting to say there will be an
exodus of the experts currently employed
by by councils elsewhere that statement
is far more powerful from the staff
whose livelihood is at stake and who
will move where the jobs are than it is
from a council who is presenting a
number of other very important Council
issues I think it's a good I I also
agree it's a good submission the only
thing I change with it is on the
suggestion that we speak I would
actually being suggested I would
actually suggest that that last the
council requests the opportunity to make
an oral submission to the committee
should include the words preferably at a
South Island in you I think it is always
worth making that point with a council
submission that we would like it heard
outside Wellington especially on
a bill of the seriousness don't just
leave it as we want to make an oral
submission actually say we want it to be
if you want to say in Dunedin even saved
it but I just think don't just leave it
there's
a submission where we have to go to
Wellington on on a bill of
substance but on on the other issue I
just I just think that on the particular
issues of the effect this will have
staff and wise there is no better
presenter than than star who are
actually living with the reality day
today it's it's an issue that'll be lost
in our general submission on the other
important issues we want to emphasize as
a council that the staff can actually
speak to
okay thank you Lisa um just before I go
to knobby
um can I ask you will the staff group of
Staff have a designated a designated
speaker
available they're going oh at the at the
silly committee the intention would be
that if they speak to it that it would
be Julie Mueller who heads up that otago
collaboration at the start at Target
Southland collaboration at a stop level
and she's based where central otaka
Alexandra okay no way so just working
through the issues that have been raised
I guess
um I don't see how we can control the
otago self and voice while we might have
10 issues raised on the Staffing issue
before I even say
um we might not be in the opposition to
follow them but it's a little bit like
you're saying well we're going to
mandate today that achieve executable
staff staff group can go away and make a
submission which we actually don't get
to see
and it's got to be in by Friday
and so uh I'm nervous about it and I
think it's our role as Government to
cover staff related issues if we don't
have this in the report that we've got
at the moment and we don't have the time
Commander which is what the chief
executive says then the starfish is lost
if I do an oral presentation I will
address that anyway because I addressed
it last time we went to Dunedin rang he
was there about the issue that they
cannot assume which they currently do
that they're just going to grab all the
water Engineers from every Council
that's not going to happen some people
will not want to transfer across some
will want to go across to the downers
and others that are going to be in this
field as well so they're being warned
about that before
um you know I just said it's it's a
terrible precedent when we start having
a voice from Council and then we have
the chief Executives or the staff group
off
um having their own voice what message
does that give to MPS well we should be
representing what what I would say is
the the key benefit that I see behind it
is that
um what we found with the national
transition unit is that where
otago's Southland councils who at an
operational working level uh work
together quite well when we're able to
use a collective voice in pushing back
we found that that's had a much better
effect than us trying to push back
individually the intention of this
wasn't to put forward anything that was
contrary to any of our councils or that
would cause any controversy with any of
our councils but to attempt to give
greater weight through a United voice on
those issues that we were particularly
key and passionate about
um that's all we were attempting to
achieve when would we be able to
um get a glimpse of the submission
um obviously it's it's
Windows yeah I'm sorry I Mr chair that's
I hear an instruction that we don't do
it so
um
that would be my preference cheer if I
get an opportunity my preference oh it
needs to be emotion yeah yeah I think
we're on this is like this is new
information I did not I did not know I
mean we've been asked to to consider our
our submission yeah but in the
background on banana certainly to me
anyway that we've got a chief Executives
staff group also doing a submission
which we don't get to see either sorry
in In fairness when we workshopped this
we did discuss the fact that there was
this separate submission what wasn't
discussed at the time was the exact
process around how it would go up and I
did advise that I would come and talk
further around that once I had the
detail so that's the detail that we're
bringing today
so my understanding of that Workshop was
that the cheap museums or the staff
group whichever you want to call it
would come back to us with the issues
that they had from a staffing Pursuit
which I thought was great I mean they're
the cold face so they know
um and that we if there was anything
significant we would have that in our
report and then now seeing as though
we've got two separate reports simply
from a time expected it's really
interesting that's never happened before
at Council I don't see the benefit while
you might well negotiate with the
national transition unit you know how
this works the national transition unit
are not bmps who are Coalition right
across Parliament
um and that's at a different level
altogether yeah
and we're not negotiating with the DIA
okay okay I'm going to move on to keep
this moving trash and then rear seems to
me that we're looking at
operational thing
now
um you will have your
um submission planned already have you
uh all right so I'm not writing it I
provided feedback into Julie Muir at
Central otago of our key issues she's
drafting it I'm expected to have the
draft tomorrow the reason that it's
coming through so late was that
obviously all of the councils had to go
away as staff and come up with their
submissions and figure out what was
important to them before a joint one
could be sorry what I'm understanding
then is that
you as a group as a staff group have
developed what you see are the issues
the perception that I would see is that
if
um invercargill city council deliver a
submission but this by themselves but
the staff collectively do it with others
it looks like a breakdown and I believe
that we could have the submission with
an operational piece
editor it now I've already been told
sorry that there's no time to do that no
they can't it's been a little time but
haven't you got it ready no so I've
given some I've given some high level
feedback on it
um it's now gone off to somebody else to
finalize and write the submission
um I'll be honest I've now turned my
attention to 1225 yeah I just I I just
see that it doesn't look good
uh Ria
um
make an observation and what this tells
me is that our staff and CEO really care
about what's going to happen in their
future under this legislation what I
want to hand out and and reach out in
sadio is so am I as a citizen Office of
the city and our rate payers are also
going to be affected I'm more for that
we have to have an absolute strong
submission that includes your voices of
the how it's going to affect our
Engineers or our team or whether we
shrink and employment or not the
knowledge that has gained through
submitting to legislative and bills is
actually through your employment
and that partially is to make sure that
as a council and counselors that we're
actually receiving that information from
our advisors quite rightly as you said
and other advisors and officials deal
with things but in the role that our
I don't mean any disrespect oh our staff
here are employed to is help us with
this legislation so when we send two
bits of um submissions coming forward
that one's very strong from Council and
one's very strong from an important
perspective and how that team's affected
it's almost sending a mixed message and
undermining the bigger need which is
actually a conjoined front for our city
our brake pads our workers everyone in
this building
right Nigel
no I thought you had your hand up I was
just very excited about hearing being
involved
that's pressurized look like this is uh
to me is to me is Cheer
uh to me it's chair like I'm I'm a bit
blindsided because I remember the
workshop and we talked about a joint
submission but I was totally under
belief it was going to be at a Joint
Council level like we are here okay
there was no indication it was going to
be a second submission at another level
now I'm aware that Central uh codc has
completely different views to this
Council on uh on the three Waters and
they're entitled to
um and I just uh is that going to be
available to us tomorrow
personal distract to look at this stop
one no so we don't have another
committee meeting ahead of when the
submission would be due so there
wouldn't be an opportunity to review it
my advice I just believe it just leave
it no well it's still going to be
submitted it's going to have every
Council if we I mean and invercargill
it's the instruction I've heard and we
accept that
um so it'll be all of region except for
us no but this is sorry this is
completely out of agenda it's out of
totally off scope and I'm not happy with
it at all
[Music]
um
right I'm going to keep going uh Leslie
then knobby
oh sorry the invercargill staff involved
in a technical submission
that would be of some use for the one
chance we have to submit on these bills
would be a major disservice we have the
assurance that this submission would be
Technical and not in any way at variance
with the more General submission we are
putting in as a council I can see no
reason why we would not take the chance
to be part of a good technical
submission on an issue that we all know
is highly technical
and is about the movement of water
Engineers around the country where
they'll move to how it might affect and
mean that various councils are abandoned
and not left with the staff that we
would expect to have
it just seems to me that this is the
only chance we have to be part of a good
technical submission as well as our very
good General submission I I just I just
can't see why it would be any disservice
to the ratepayers invercargill to have
us as part of a technical submission
that might actually drive some points
home that are pretty important in this
whole issue of these two bills
okay before I go carry on I'm going to
actually state that this is a technical
submission if you read the 54 paragraphs
there are there's a lot of technical
detail about all sorts of matters
concerning three Waters and and I guess
as chair I can't see why this is not a
an addition to the one we're submitting
um and and it would have been added on
to all all of the council's submissions
instead of 54 paragraphs it might be so
77. yeah my understanding is that we had
a discussion a little bit earlier around
where we're at compared to some of our
other Council counterparts
um there's a significant amount on
people's agendas at the moment and for
the most part my understanding is that
the other councils aren't as far
progressed with their submissions as
what we are so it simply wasn't a
position to have a joint submission
ready at this time
um it is something that will be you know
going down to the wire in terms of
timing
um as the chief Executives advised
though we've we've taken on board the
feedback we'll we'll simply advise that
it's not something that ICC wishes to
progress with at this time
well this is I mean we've had some
comments made but this is there's no
formal decision being made we are just
thrashing it out and getting it out in
the open and trying to understand it I I
don't think the feedback is anyway we no
way
um would I
um interpret we want it gone or we want
it to stay we're just trying to
understand it as I'm sure you can
understand if there were some councils
that had had Council approval of a
submission and some that hadn't had a
chance to do that yet that provides some
difficulty in terms of the submission
that's the the main reasoning behind
having it going up as as a staff
submission because not all councils have
had an opportunity to meet and have
subcommittees that meet before the end
of the month
um so again as I say we're really just
trying to reiterate those key points
that we've already put forward in our
submission and draw those out a little
bit more in a joint submission saying
that these are the key things that that
all of the councils really want to
stress but again the practicality of
being able to do that at an officer
level but if the feedback is is that we
we are concerned about the perception
that that provides then we're happy to
take on board that feedback and and not
create make that issue
right like I'm gonna end just the
discussion on that very subject at the
moment until the end and if need be we
can add it as another recommendation
um because I think it's distracting us
from the current submission it's going
to keep moving on and Grant no I was
going to speak to that so okay we'll
just look I think we need to pack that
up benefits
staffs are suggesting it's uh they're
going to withdraw it and we're just
trying to understand it I think we'll
just park it until we come to the end of
discussion around the 54 paragraphs
we've got so continuing there
um like I've got a question around
um
surround funding for the whole for the
for this whole project and they don't it
really scares me
um I went on the lgfa website today and
and they disclose how much they
currently loan to all the councils in
New Zealand and um that is 14 billion
dollars at the moment and assume perhaps
half of that is three Waters related
probably this but we'll go half seven
billion dollars now that is that's for
three Waters activities now that has
been being serviced at the moment by New
Zealand All of New Zealand
The Proposal under the three water
scheme is to increase that debt to 180
billion dollars 25 times now if you've
got a a country servicing with the rates
we're paying now
7 million
how
how can you possibly service
180 billion dollars and
pay what they claim under efficiencies
and everything something Equitable the
math doesn't work for me so I'm going to
pass over to Michael to see if he can if
he might shiny light
on on the subject something like that
and then this is assuming that the
entities can borrow at a rate very close
to lgfa
uh thank you thank you chair for that
um
looking at
looking at the debt I would have have to
say you need to take into account all of
the local Authority debt bits there as
well in relation to that servicing
because we're servicing a portion of
debt as well so that the figure first
stated
um gives you one one number but there's
also all the local entity did as well
combined that's being serviced via rates
so you've got tax and rates paying for
debt at the moment having said that
there is a significant increase in the
debt to be serviced and there will be
some increase in one of those particular
areas either through tax or rates to
service IT service that debt
um that that is a given if you increase
the debt you need to increase the
servicing charge somewhere
um that is the principle that they've
provided
that'll be shared across all of the
users of the three Waters through the
four entities
um other than that I can't comment any
further because it'll be the finances
within the entities that will provide
that advice and recommendation coming
back so what I'm getting at is we've had
no real indication
of of the reality that sits in front of
us of what's going to happen because
um say that 7 billion is actually 14
billion regardless it's still
180 billion is 10 times
you know so I just I'm really struggling
here but it's not in our submission
um questioning
um this Abyss we're heading into but uh
I guess
um we just sit back I think chair we did
draw that a
point out during our submission to the
first piece of legislation to the water
services entity bill
um around our concerns around how the
debt figures stacked up and the impact
for invercargill city
um so that was something that we did put
forward as part of our first submission
right no that's fine I appreciate that
Michael thanks okay uh any further
comments regarding uh our submission
no okay well I'm gonna get back to
um whether we're happy to let the staff
put in the submission I mean I can't the
submission is going ahead the fact that
invercargill doesn't put its name on it
it still goes forward and it looks it
creates something else rare so I'm going
to apologize
um I was a bit slow to react
um before you asked was there any more
comments on the submission
ah
when I'm reading through this and I had
a look through it
there's some key concerns and through
this com this submission
um which I think one of them I loved it
was 0.5
of the um council's key concerns
um
and throughout the submission we've
referred to quite a few other
organizations like lgnz which is fine
but there seems to be no actual data
information put in here to show the
effects and adverse effects of what this
legislation will do to us down here
there's no information in terms of like
revenue or cost impacts on us either and
those things should be in there um what
we have got I'll step in here because
back in 20
21 or 20 percent uh we had to submit
yeah the first one and that was a
detailed Financial one that showed where
we would be in 20 2050
Etc uh and that we would be far worse
off and I've explained why okay so and
the mentions in here that letter sure so
some of those people sitting on those
chairs now today wouldn't have been
there when you we put the submission
through right so I guess what I'm saying
is that we need to make sure that we are
consistent with following up that
absolute risk factor to us and a set of
eyes looking at those figures we'll go
to those figures before they go to the
words
and the statements so you're saying
there would be attachments sorry Mr
chair the the way in which that could be
dealt with would be to it has been
referred to in the 54 paragraphs as yeah
keeps referring to we could actually
attach it yes uh and that would answer
yes
yeah that's brilliant no because they're
first letter when we were asked either
opt-in or opt out
very specific
um there was no ambiguity there
whatsoever right
um let's get we're getting back to now
the point about the staff submission the
combined Council staff submission and
we're talking just to get it clear
um the councils involved uh
um the three from down here Dunedin
clutha codc Queenstown any further north
right turkey waitaki
um like the only concern for me is the
fact that
yeah won't be Queenstown would they be
involved yeah yeah absolutely
I think that's something else yeah um
it's just something something I haven't
seen you know and and and it you know
I've got
full faith that it represents you know a
different view
um and the content would be about the
only about the impact on staff is that
right
to draw weight to the key pieces of
um that we've wanted to focus on things
like the the debt allocation schedule it
does go into a little bit more detail
around that but those key principles why
would the entity not pay rates why would
the entity not take the whole stormwater
piece I think the other thing to keep in
context is that there are some councils
who have perhaps not had these staff
resource to throw at unpicking this
legislation and preparing a submission
in their own right this is their
opportunity to collaborate with other
councils and all go yes we agree that
that's not right either we'd like to do
a joint submission it's a little bit of
that pooling the resources that we have
available to try to get those key points
that we all agree on across
um but again if that's causing some
concerns and some uncertainty for people
then that's fine
um I guess there's a little bit
sometimes a little bit of a um a
different
uh different concerns at a political
level than perhaps what there are at a
staff level
um look I I think I'm gonna I'm gonna
lead up as chair
I'm going to
um give give full trust that the staff
um one will
will be a specific nature and support
what we're putting in
um so but I will
um add it to actually for me to vote on
this I'm going to have to which I'll
have to I'm gonna have to put a second
fourth recommendation update yeah
um right so the someone give some
wording please to a recommendation that
just Council endorses to combine staff
submission
or is it for Zone sex or for anybody or
any more comments on the staff
submission now
anyone want to speak Trish
sorry I just want to know what you're
going to do tomorrow if the joint
submission comes back and it really
doesn't reflect what invercargill
council operational team means
given where other councils are at with
their submissions and the fact that the
person pulling it together has just come
back off leave it will very strongly
represent the views of DCC and ICC as
being the only two who have actually
done their submissions at this stage
thank you
anywhere there where there was a point
of contention where everybody didn't
agree we'd simply remove that point
okay
so just to clarify through huge here
when it comes back it won't involve
Aaron
in the sense of any additional work I
need to be very clear is that correct
yes until the end of this week no no no
no as of tomorrow is it Friday no no I
just need to be clear
is that correct you'll need to read it
no well actually the three Waters thing
is the highest priority
um thing at the moment for Council there
will be a small amount of work Nigel
that I'll be able to manage within my
1225 obligations
foreign for you and not 12 25.
yes
um I'm still a lot I'm still lost on
this prices
um we've got an undetermined
indeterminate uh report coming we don't
know who it's coming from maybe driven
by us in Dunedin maybe not it might have
parts that we're not happy with
um and it'll be not seen by any Council
around this table I suspect
and then we'll put our names to it I'm
not going to be party to that
um but I would also say that it's really
interesting that Aaron quoted more
technical detail than what we've
currently gone into our report now what
does that tell NPS if we put in some
um very overarching statements around
some things around debt and other things
and then we get a more technical report
that comes from a group of Staff of
which only two councils are really
contributing to it I mean I just don't
get that and then we don't even get to
see what we committed to so so just
getting ahead around it when they
receive it as as each Council going to
attach
the staff report to the report that
we've got here so we send that into
um Dunedin sends their report plus the
staff report so they effectively get
an appendix or is it just come in from
out of the blue from start
submitted through a separate stream
there'd be two two separate submissions
going up one from
um invercargill city council one from
each and every other Council that wants
to submit in its own right and one that
is going through from the coordinator on
behalf of otago Southland who would then
submit that on behalf of the chief
Executives
for you Jim so interesting around this
table who knows who that person is going
to present at uh at the submission
select committee on behalf of the
staff anybody know who that person is
you can see that he's shaking for
yourself this is a governance issue
that's really important on three Waters
probably the biggest issue we're going
to face on this term as it was last term
to give that Authority away and to say
that we need to have a star voice when
we should be covering all the key points
that the staff have right here now and
if we don't have time to amend the
report then the report goes as far as
I'm concerned
um I wouldn't attach anything from other
councils because I've seen recently what
happened on the health issue that we had
at Dunedin Hospital it was a shambles
and if you want to get the minister or
in peace attention you'd be very clear
that you don't give a mixed message from
different sources because it makes a
question why would we need staff to
submit on this bill if we've done a good
job ourselves
well it tells them that your council's
weak great
no I'm sorry can I can I just say but
that's based from experience what it
tells me is that we're actually trying
to plug a gap for those councils who
haven't had the resource to submit in
their own right well
I'd say outputting that's all we're
trying to do is put extra weight to our
own views but we're quite happy if we're
saying that to pull it and my view on
that is our job is to advocate for our
rate payers if there is some joint
capacity that certainly adds weight but
we don't even know what the other
councils are submitting on other than
probably what's happening in Dunedin and
Aaron has just said the other councils
aren't up to speed the deadline is this
Friday and and the other issue for me is
which is what Nigel raised was that
we've got a massive amount of paperwork
on Project 1225 that Aaron has to get
her eyes across in the next three or
four days so it's just it's a nonsense
to be going off and doing another report
it really is
accordingly
right any
um any further discussion
right could I recommend here that we do
each of the four recommendations yeah um
I'm definitely doing that thank you so
we'll start with recommendation five
right now
can we take one two and three together
we'll do one two three
so yes we need to clarify three yes okay
so three
um I'm going to put that we do actually
can we change that to does so sorry do
we have them over in a second no no not
yet I'm just gonna change that I
understand that's the move yeah so I'll
move one two and three with does in a
second I'll see yep thank you and
secondly
okay so that it does speak can I can I
just
oh yeah convenient convenient
geographical location or something like
that yeah you need any words right it's
preferably in the same file in the south
yeah we know it can't be we can invite
you we'll add that to the submission
yeah
no sorry it's under three
number three when was the last time I'm
sorry Mr chair councilor sopa wanted the
submission change to say that it doesn't
have the recommendation
and we will ensure that that Edition is
made don't worry about anything okay now
paragraphs yeah yeah I think okay sorry
about that
okay
um we've had it moved and uh seconded
for one two and three I'm gonna put
those that motion all those in favor all
right against they are carried now we'll
move to
recommendation for that the committee
acknowledges that and otago Southlands
Mission has been prepared by the
regional three Waters direct and
confirms her submission should include
invercargill city council could we note
staff submission yeah
that's a good idea
okay so
you're moving it moved before seconded
Barry and we're going to put the motion
for number four
all those in favor
aye
against
I
um
yeah I'm against yeah
yeah so what are we one two
it's lost
again yeah
okay it's four is lost
we haven't got 13 voting members here
Britain I've only got 12 voters twelve
eleven
uh councilor Campbell's way and uh
Evelyn has left
yeah Sunset of 15.
great we're about 30. it's thirteen
thirteen yeah
yeah
so could I have my could I have my vote
recorded yeah so anyone who wants the
votes noted I think we'll do that
yeah could we please make it note that
this is not a reflection on the staff
yeah
I just like my my vote recorded as well
okay
I can understand both sides for me as
chair I find it difficult about
something I know nothing about and it's
not the way I like I can do sorry
yeah and I appreciate it appreciate
other people's views as well so
okay
um
no further
items on this particular agenda so that
is the end of the extraordinary
infrastructure meeting today thanks
everybody
I might have forgot the apologies
no not at all
I'm happy that we had a democratic
person
okay Valentine's Day
um
the streaming thank you